previously I don't see this it can only
new kidnap me hey I want to go home
Marty I'm sorry but I'm afraid you're
stuck here yeah I can't be stuck here I
got a life
[Music]
vince establishes early that Gilligan's
Island will take its time and find
beauty in every shot but 14 seconds of
landscape for and it's still 14 seconds
of landscape board I mean we can all
admit that this is as spectacularly
glorious as a pair of pants falling from
the sky could be but how on earth are
they falling this slowly this far in
front of the meth mobile when they came
off of it like this
Walter chooses tighty whities over boxer
briefs and that is most definitely a sin
all hail the miracle shirt not only does
this hanger somehow stay on the mirror
after speeding down the road a note
decent-sized crash the shirt stays on
the hanger when it wasn't even buttoned
Skyler you awful love of my life I hope
you know that Walter jr. my big man damn
it Cranston how did you not win all the
Emmys oh wait you almost did add to that
this may be the best first three minutes
of a show in the history of television
and I think we're going to have to drive
this sin total in Reverse for a second I
know TV shows think openings like this
are clever but if we know what the end
result is going to be then we're
essentially watching a prequel the rest
of the way and I hate prequels birthday
birthday bacon which would normally not
be a sin I mean who doesn't want
delicious bacon on their birthday but
since it's veggie bacon we are now in
sin territory chemistry it is the study
of chemicals no chemistry is the study
of matter chemical is the type of matter
and didn't want quiz me here know that
most people would be guessing chemicals
Jeff is there something wrong with your
table this is a favorite question at all
but how did Chad even get away with
going back there in the first place
ionic bonds chapter 6 wait what Chapter
six if they're already this far into the
school year why won't have to go into is
very dramatic what is chemistry speech
earlier which seems like extremely first
day material Oh considering he has to
presumably teach all day and then go to
work at a car wash how was it even
possible he gets off at 5:00 a Skyler
insinuated he did earlier that morning
you get paid till 5:00 you work till 5
o'clock 22 that's my daily care since
this gun is loaded and he has one in the
chamber
he's being awful cavalier about leaving
nothing around for someone who should
know better
I met my reserve and there's still two
minutes e-bay oh hey so what's up for
Saturday casual [ __ ] is casual what
does guy
No is he asleep missus mocks half masted
mister after half asked half fast half
mastered tasks masterfully fully baiting
her mister with this massive
masturbation mister why are you a smoker
he asks because he apparently just
diagnosed your lung cancer with a
stethoscope against your back for two
seconds just like they teach in medical
school you understood what I've just
said to you yes lung cancer inoperable
and this was diagnosed in the same
afternoon so how was your day how is it
possible that Skyler doesn't know he
went to the hospital even if his job
didn't call her to get all these tests
done and meet with a doctor would have
taken a lot longer than he was supposed
to be at work and then there's the fact
that he would have had the car at the
hospital since he rode in the ambulance
[Music]
that's a racist I mean didn't Skyler
take care of that just the other night
not everything is about you Walter it's
a green light wow the one day that Walt
asks Hank to ride along there's a
massive meth bust and Hank just correct
a different case on Walt's birthday I
know drugs are an epidemic and all but
does this seriously happen every day in
Albuquerque the Cherry's convenient for
our story that somehow only Walter gets
to see this completely conspicuous
rooftop escape dance also wouldn't you
just carry your clothing out with you
and find somewhere hidden before trying
to put anything on you ain't Welcome
Back Kotter so step off no speeches
Welcome Back Kotter
Jesse lanes here is what in his 20s
meaning Kotter would've been long gone
by the time he was even born sure he
might know the reference but I'm
guessing he would have sooner thrown out
a mr. Feeny miss bliss or miss Frizzle
hell I wouldn't even be surprised if a a
Ron Paul here would be more apt to drop
a mr. Garvey reference before Welcome
Back Kotter you want to cook crystal
meth it's late and maybe no one's out or
near by but this does seem more like an
indoorsy kind of conversation you
wouldn't apply heat to a volumetric
flask that's what a boiling flask is for
did you learn nothing from my chemistry
class I know the show is emphasizing
Jesse's lack of knowledge here but I'm
pretty sure most of the known universe
couldn't tell you the difference between
a volumetric flask and a boiling flask
so team Jesse all the way on this one
all of a sudden aids what 60 he's just
gonna break bad roll commercials big
dumb jocks believe the disabled cliche
cool moment to show won't growing a pair
but what just happened he told Skyler
and won't jr. to cool it then walked out
of the back of the store
then came around to the front why does
this somehow amp up the bad attitude and
you're maybe only the world's second
biggest amo so who's the first she'll
always leaving us hanging granted I've
only cooked meth once maybe five times
so I don't know the entire process but
if Walt is such a stickler about purity
shouldn't he be using gloves the entire
[ __ ] time you know how good this show
is it makes a chemistry montage exciting
and cool did you hear me a chemistry
montage I don't wanna do it any more
than you but the rules are the rules
another setup hasn't you been watching
way too much Miami Vice you see Miami
Vice was a show from the past that was
then a movie and is being rebooted as a
show again by Vin Diesel alongside
MacGyver fuller house dynasty the
Connors Will and Grace and Hawaii five-o
because apparently creating new shows
there's too hard or something I know
this isn't this shows fault but I'm
breaking mad and someone has to pay the
price some stole fine sick sick you've
been cooking there is a show has dropped
the slang tic tic Conte and jib head and
now I'm concerned that Vince may have
actually become a drug dealer to write
this show stay safe Vincent we care
about you Walter in the middle how
exactly is the only brush on fire
directly behind the RV when Emilio threw
his cigarette out the side window how
did the fire department get to this fire
so quickly it's barely even started and
we've established they're out in the
middle of nowhere there's no way anyone
would have had time to spot that smoke
call it in and have them get there in 15
minutes since the fire to get also I
know they're super concerned about the
brush fire but these are emergency
vehicles right isn't at least one of
them concerned about a do Tanner's
underwear standing in the road next to
what's pretty obviously a crash I mean
at least call that in
that's going to chafe my willy
chemistry it is the study of what anyone
anyone anyone the Great Depression take
it take your shot
take your nutty shop 101 totally cool
science experiments for kids you know
cuz you're so into science this is glass
grade this is pure glass believe me mr.
Barnes some kind of notice you just get
over it it's nudity just because you're
ashamed of your body doesn't mean
everybody should be I'd be willing to
sell it to you if the price is right
[Music]